I've been more successful as a writer
than I was as arrests sir I never won a
major tournament as a wrestler I got
close but anybody who's done any sport
knows that that's close doesn't make
make you happy I did it for a long time
I competed as a wrestler for 20 years
from the age of 14 until I was 34 maybe
too long given the arthritis in my
fingers and neck but it was the first
discipline I was exposed to it was the
first thing that I applied myself to
with a tremendous amount of focus and
determination and as a young kid you
know as an early teenager you can be
more proficient athletically at a
younger age then you can ever expect to
be proficient as a writer as a 14 15 16
year old my pursuit of wrestling and
writing were simultaneous similar
simultaneous they happened
simultaneously simultaneously they they
came together I began writing and
wrestling at the age of 14 but for a
number of years of course I I was
rewarded as a wrestler I could see my
progress as a wrestler long before I
recognized any discernible progress as a
as a fiction writer but it was terribly
useful to me to apply myself to this
discipline there was so much repetition
involved that I think it has helped me
the wrestling as a writer because of how
much revision rewriting is a part of my
writing process and I think I have
developed the stamina or the expectation
that rewriting is part of the job and an
essential part of the job I think that
comes from my training as an athlete